[Music]
so there is so much career advice for
the best career advice that you are not
getting is to invest what what that has
absolutely nothing to do with my
performance a job yes but it does have
to do with having more money and if you
are investing to the same extent of the
guys are that will on average and has
historically added to your wealth
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
someone and millions of dollars over the
course of their lives what happens when
you've got more money you can play
looser right you can with more
confidence go in ask for that promotion
for that overseas assignment quit that
job you cannot stand because that boss
is such a jerk start your own business
you know test your own business the
degrees of freedom when we've got more
money are substantial and I'll even take
it you know all the way to also help us
get to equality with men that confidence
in the workforce that equality ladies we
will not be equal with men until we are
financially equal with men so the best
career advice you're not getting is to
invest I wish I didn't have to give you
this advice that I wish every company
out there just let you be you you know
and that you're just not comfortable
going in and negotiating for the raise
and not to force you to do it to pay at
close that gender pay gap pay everybody
exactly what they're worth and not make
negotiating a core part of getting
compensated in this country so I wish I
didn't have to do that but I do and so
we have to accept the world as it is
today and so ladies you got to negotiate
from the first job you just have to and
let me give you the example why so I've
managed a lot of people over a lot of
years and I will tell you that every
year almost every guy who reported to me
before bonus time would come into my
office and tell me how
they wanted to make and every guy every
year typically told me more than he was
in the budget for to think about what
happens right Jim and Mary Jim and Mary
are both in the budget for a bonus or
raise of five each Jim comes in tells me
he wants 10 never hear from Mary I
giggle to myself that Jim he's so crazy
you know we're never paid him too well
comes around time to put the budget
together give out the raises or the
bonuses and I know my HR head and I both
know Jim wants 10 well you know we're
not going to pay him 10 but you know his
office door was closed the other day and
the guys on the street are looking for
someone like Jim and by the way he made
a really good point I totally forgot
about the project he did we'll pay him
seven now how much does Mary make the
answer usually is five the right answer
of course is three because just because
Jim asked for more and I choose to give
a more doesn't mean my bonus pool goes
up doesn't mean my budget goes up and so
there is to some extent a zero-sum game
all right ladies now that I've convinced
you how do we approach it with facts so
much of the and in advance so much of
the be advice to us is sort of in the
meaning in the moment you just start
planting those seeds well before first
of all you need to know how much you
should be making and go to a
payscale.com or get raised or comparable
or higher to any of these services that
are popping up talk to your friends have
two glasses of wine or four you don't
have the conversations so no how much
you should make have the conversation in
advance with your boss about what our if
possible the metrics how many new
quantified it extends you can how many
new reports helmet kind of client
satisfaction score how many new clients
what in sales how many clean audits
whatever it is you can quantify what
does success look like so set that up
for this is success for me the
department for the company here's what I
need to achieve this year here's what I
want to make right get an agreement and
then the negotiation being beer is not a
negotiation you know
to the extent of course that you come in
you've done that or haven't done it
never take never have one ask and take
no for an answer that if you're told
though on the raise or even if you're
told yes come in with twelve other
requests right I want you know to take a
coding class of the company pays for I
want to have a stint in marketing I want
to work overseas for a period of time I
want to be mentored by X Y Z I want to
work on this big project I wanna I wanna
I wanna
and it's by number 20 you know typically
your boss is going to say yes to
something that can turn into
professional advancement or money down
the road and if he or she says no at all
xx I think you've gotten a pretty clear
message there as well
[Music]